a parent's worst nightmare the suspected
gas poisoning of school girls has been
going on for months and across various
parts of Iran I felt like I smelled
paint I have very severe numbness in my
body I can't walk at all many describe
similar symptoms a strange smell
numbness their teacher backing them up
my job because the students all felt the
same symptoms as me they had coughs some
of them said their eyes burned and most
of them were scared
there have been protests calling for an
investigation it's rare that this kind
of footage makes it out of Iran
and it has reached the highest levels
Iran's supreme leader has called for
those responsible to be held to account
this is an important issue if they're
really hands involved and people groups
are involved in this matter this is a
big and unforgivable crime responsible
agencies intelligence services and law
enforcement agencies must pursue them
and the perpetrators must be condemned
to severe punishment it is a serious and
unforgivable crime there will be no
amnesty for them
the United Nations has weighed in
calling for a transparent investigation
Iran has rejected what it calls foreign
meddling however president Ibrahim raisi
has now assigned a working group to
investigate Stephanie Decker or Jazeera